be six at the Berlin Olympic Games in
Germany Adolf Hitler witnessed American
sprinter Jesse Owens son of a
sharecropper grandson of a slave win
four gold medals next on book TV Jeremy
shap on his new book triumph the untold
story of Jesse Owens and Hitler's
Olympics from the University of Buffalo
in New York this is an hour this is your
NPR station 88 7w BFO public radio from
UB this is meet the author and I'm Burt
jam bidding tonight's show coming to you
from the Student Union Theatre on the
University at Buffalo North Campus a
program made possible in part by you
bees Division of Student Affairs and our
media co-sponsor Buffalo rising calm
we'd also like to welcome a crew from
c-span here to tape tonight's visit for
later broadcast as part of its book TV
presentation our meet the author guest
tonight is Jeremy chef and this month's
election is his new book triumph the
untold story of Jesse Owens and Hitler's
Olympics Jesse Owens performance in
Berlin more than 70 years ago ranks
among the greatest achievements in
sports history it is also one of the
great ironies in sports history that
those achievements were as much about
refuting a national agenda as defeating
opponents all in an environment which
was supposed to be devoid of politics as
the games approached the Germans
carefully and insidiously concealed the
signs of hatred as they made promises of
fairness that they had no intention of
keeping in the u.s. many believed that
American athletes should not be part of
such an obvious Nazi propaganda vehicle
that boycott effort did not succeed
Jesse Owens did and before the summer of
1936 was over America's greatest hero as
famous as anyone in the country who's
single-handedly crushed the Nazi notion
of racial superiority at the same time
he confronted racial prejudice at home
would be stripped of his amateur status
when exhausted and broke he withdrew
from the final leg of an AAU exhibition
tour Owens trained as an athlete but the
circumstances and the stay
pushed him in other directions social
and political I'm looking forward to
exploring those directions and exploring
this story tonight with our guest the
author of the new book triumph the
untold story of Jesse Owens and Hitler's
Olympics please join me now in welcoming
to WB fo and the University at Buffalo
our meet the author guest jeremy chef
thank you very gently to open the the
program by asking you to to read from
the book if you will specifically the
the prologue which really sets the scene
for for later discussion my pleasure i
just before 9:30 p.m. Central Time on
September 23rd 1955 in a handsome
townhouse on Chicago's South Side James
Cleveland Owen slipped into a tweed
jacket and sat down in a straight back
chair as he smoothed out his pencil
mustache and slicked back his hair what
little was left left of it a dozen
technicians put the finishing touches on
what had been an all-day job wiring and
lighting the Owens home in a few minutes
Owens would be talking live on national
TV with Edward Armour of CBS on his
celebrity interview show person a person
more than twenty million Americans would
watch as Murrow spoke from a studio in
New York first with Owens and his family
and then in the second half of the show
with Leonard Bernstein in his a 42 year
old father of three Jesse Owens weighed
25 pounds more than he had in Berlin in
1936 when he turned in the most
indelible performance ever at the
Olympic Games in his conservative jacket
flannel slacks white shirt and dark tie
he could have passed for a
fifty-year-old
not that he wasn't in superb shape he
was in fact just a few months earlier he
had run a hundred yards in nine point
nine seconds less than a second slower
than his personal bests he still held
the world record in both the broad jump
now called the long jump and the 4 by
100 meter relay though both records in
mid said in the mid 1930s for his part
Murrow was readying himself for another
half-hour banality 'he's no one confused
person a person
see it now murrow's other show on CBS
the one on which 18 months earlier he
had neutered Senator Joseph McCarthy
despite the fluff Murrow was eager to
speak with note with Owens whose legend
had grown significantly since 1936 here
Murrow thought was a legitimate American
hero the man who had humbled the Third
Reich for Owens the appearance with
Murrow was emblematic of his enhanced
stature in the 15 years since his
athletic career ended he had struggled
to find his way professionally and
financially he'd made more money than
the vast majority of his fellow
Americans in the dry-cleaning business
at Ford motors working for the state of
Illinois but the windfall he expected in
the aftermath of his Olympic heroics
never materialized banned from amateur
competition after an imbroglio with
American track officials he'd raced
against horses most famously in Havana
in December 1936 defeating Julio macaw a
five-year old bay gelding after the
horse spotted him a 40-yard advantage in
1938 on the occasion of the first night
baseball game at Ebbets Field he raced
to speedy Major League outfielders
spotting them several yards he Barnes
stormed with a black baseball team and
campaign for the Republican presidential
candidate Alf Landen in countless ways
he had sold himself but he never had
much to show for it until now by the
time Owens sat down to speak with Murrow
he was well on his way to becoming an
institution to Jesse Owens who would
spend the rest of his life telling his
story to appreciative audiences around
the world the Jesse Owens who could have
been a hero from Horatio Alger if
Alger's heroes had not all been white in
the years after his Olympic victories
his achievements in Berlin had been
overshadowed by World War two but by
1955 at the end of the first decade of
the Cold War he was finally getting his
due he was in demand as a banquet
speaker and making good money because
he'd become useful to industry in
government as a symbol of the
opportunity America the opportunities
America promised and sometimes delivered
to the delight of white America and most
of black America he disputed the
sentiments of Paul Robeson the
all-american football player turned
actor singer who famously suggested that
African Americans
would not and should not fight for the
United States in the event of war with
the Soviet Union
Owens and contrast held himself out as
an example of what black Americans could
achieve
despite the indignities and slights he
had suffered his entire life he agreed
with Jackie Robinson who in his 1949
testimony before the house on American
Activities Committee had said that
blacks had too much invested in the
American experiment to support its
enemies just a few days after his
appearance on person a person Owens was
to embark at the behest of the State
Department on a goodwill
goodwill tour of Singapore Malaya the
Philippines in India as a.m. Rosenthal
then the New York Times correspondent in
South Asia put it Owens his mission was
to make friends for the United States
having fought the fascist the fascists
with his fleetness of foot he would now
fight the Communists with his charm and
rhetoric even though some Indian writers
Unversed in the annals of the Olympics
confused him with sir Owen Dixon an
Australian judge and United Nations
mediator before the long ride to the
subcontinent though there was the
interview with Murrow whose fondness for
bespoke tailoring matched his own
finally at 9:30 were the cigarette
clenched in his left hand Murrow began
the interview Jesse Owens he said is
generally recognized as the greatest
track star of the last half century his
performance in Berlin stands unmatched
in modern times statistics will never
indicate Adolf Hitler's reaction as he
watched a 23 year old boy from Danville
Alabama run the athletes of the master
race right into the ground
Owens whose politeness was among his
defining characteristics declined to
correct Murrow by pointing out that he
had been 22 not 23 and was from Oakville
Alabama not Danville he simply smiled
and waited for the questions he knew
were coming the questions that always
came after several minutes of amiable
chatter you look to be in almost good
enough condition to get out your old
track shoes again and the introduction
of Owens his wife and three pretty
daughters Murrow offered him the
opportunity to talk about the games of
the 11th Olympiad Jesse Owens he said
what's your warmest memory of that
August of 1936 Owens had been asked that
quest
Nords Varian's perhaps hundreds of times
he did not hesitate I remember a boy he
said his accent betraying no hint of his
Southern roots that I competed against
in the broad jump a boy with whom I
built a friendship and we corresponded
for a number of years and then the war
broke out and I didn't hear any more
from him at all
Owens looked down and away from the
camera the boy he was referring to was
Lutz long the silver medalist a pure
blooded Aryan from Leipzig who'd helped
him reach the broad jump finals when
he'd been on the verge of
disqualification composing himself Owens
talked about long son Kai Owens and kyod
met in 1951 and then about winning the
hundred meter dash but he had not yet
answered murrow's question I think that
the greatest moment that a person can
have is to stand on a victory stand he
said farawayfromhome and then from the
distance you can hear the strains of the
star-spangled banner and then suddenly
you make a left turn and you see the
Stars and Stripes rising higher and
higher and the higher the Stars and
Stripes rose the louder the strains of
the Star Spangled Banner would be heard
I think that's the greatest moment of my
whole athletic career as the proof
finally moved his couch and coffee table
back where they belong to into the deep
indentations in the carpet Owens and his
wife Ruth carefully returned his
memorabilia to display case a few
special items had been freed from the
case temporarily from Moreau and his
audience to see clearly they were there
were the bran spikes and the medals the
laurel wreaths all the tokens of his
youthful greatness he had collected them
19 years earlier in Germany with the
eyes of the world fixed on him in an
atmosphere charged by an ascending Third
Reich on a continent that would soon
convulse convulse and warn genocide
nothingjust
Jesse Owens did at the Olympic Stadium
diminished the horrors to come he saved
no lives however for those paying close
enough attention owens and berlin
revealed essential truths while the
western democracies were perfecting the
art of appeasement while much of the
rest of the world kowtow to the nazis
owen stood up to them at their own
olympics refuting their venomous
theories with his awesome deeds as
jeremy shap reading from the prologue of
his new book our meet the author
selection for this month triumph the
unto
story of Jesse Owens and Hitler's
Olympics Jeremy to begin if we look at
the place that track-and-field held in
the minds of American sports fans in the
1930s it's a very different place from
what the sport holds today for American
sports fans
well track-and-field today is in many
ways in the u.s. dead sport people
barely pay attention I think there are a
few factors at play first of all the
drug scandals that rocked the sport
going back to even before Ben Johnson in
1988 the Canadian gold medallist and
soul who tested positive for steroids
and was stripped of the gold medal but I
think it's a sport that in many ways was
most attractive to Americans when this
was a more rural society running and
jumping field events those were the
things that that I think young people
did when they were living away from
cities when they had room to run in to
play in that way and in that way it's a
lot like harness racing which the turn
of the 20th century was among our most
popular sports and now you'd be
hard-pressed to find any coverage of it
in the mainstream press it was linked
indelibly to to this country's rural
roots and in the 1930s when Jesse Owens
was was competing it was up there with
baseball horse-racing and college
football as the preeminent sports
thousands of people showed up to see
Jesse Owens compete when he broke a
whole bunch of world records at a famous
meet in 1935 it was front-page news
everywhere figures such as Will Rogers
wrote about him every day in the papers
his achievement was recognized
universally he became an overnight
sensation and familiar it's almost
everyone and even as recently as 1950
The Associated Press polled 393 sports
writers for their definitive mid-century
sports poll and asked them to name the
most significant athlete of the first
half of the 20th century
so the top 18 were track stars more than
in any other sport if we were to do such
a pole for the last 50 years of 393
sports writers if we came up with one
track star in the top 18 Carl Lewis I
might be surprised
you mentioned certainly not more you
mentioned that meet in 35 36 certainly
cemented his his celebrity and his his
place in history but his athletic
reputation at least the cornerstone of
his athletic reputation was really laid
at that meet in Ann Arbor in 1935 II it
is it's it's what he achieves in Ann
Arbor at the Big Ten championships on
May 25th 1935 and that's the starting
point for me in the book after the
prologue it's so remarkable that people
I respect sports historians people that
I know who really care about the history
of sport are familiar with the great
moments still many of them consider it
the greatest single day accomplishment
ever
I mean you think about anything anybody
has done will Chamberlain scoring a
hundred points in Hershey Pennsylvania
you know Lou Gehrig hitting four home
runs in a single game Reggie Jackson
hitting three home runs in consecutive
pitches in the 1977 World Series Jesse
Owens the Big Ten championships in Ann
Arbor with a sore back he had spent the
night before the finals getting rubbed
down hot tubs he'd fallen down the
stairs fooling around it his fraternity
house at Ohio State with some friends he
gets out onto the track and in the space
of less than an hour there's some
dispute whether it was 55 minutes or 45
minutes but it was pretty clearly less
than an hour
he breaks five world records and ties
another in four different events in the
100-yard dash 220 yard dash the 220 yard
hurdles and the broad jump there the
records are almost all of them
remarkably durable in fact the broad
jump record he sets
he jumps 26
feet eight and a quarter inches which is
more than which is half a foot farther
than any human being has ever previously
leaped farther than he would ever again
leap and the world record until 1959 you
mentioned that he's at his athletic peak
in Ann Arbor yet he's still improving in
many ways in what ways was he he he's
not he believe it or not as great as he
was and Jesse Owens is a guy who's been
a star since he was in high school he's
he's had remarkable times that made him
among the fastest people in the world
since he's 17 years old 18 years old in
high school but he never had a good
start he was uh he just couldn't quite
get out of the blocks the weren't
actually blocks most the time when he
was racing it was it was a relatively
recent innovation but he couldn't get a
quick start and over the course of the
next few months it became it becomes a
major national even international story
the Jesse Owens can be beaten because
he's not great at getting a good start
in a race and that's why as great as he
was at a hundred yards and it's metric
equivalent and all the records he said
at those distances he was a much
stronger 200 meter 220 yard sprinter
because over the length of that distance
you could compensate for whatever poor
start you might have had and and how
much of this story how much of the Jesse
Owens story is tied to his relationship
with good coaches I think a lot of it I
mean there are two two coaches in his
life there is the coach who discovers
him
when he's in elementary school even
before he gets to junior high school
Charles Reilly who is you know I've got
this picture of him in my mind from
having you know researched him and seen
photographs of him he's 50 years old
when he first sees Jesse Owens but he
looks like he's 70 he's got white hair
he's extremely frail he's short he
weighs maybe a hundred
pounds he he grew up
first generation son of immigrants from
Ireland grew up in mocked chunk
Pennsylvania which was a mining town but
known at the turn of the 20th century is
the Switzerland of America the richest
town in the u.s. because it had such a
high percentage of millionaires from the
mining industry he was not from the rich
side of town and he spots and Jesse
Owens literally as he's running around
the schoolyard this remarkable talent
he's a huge sports enthusiast he loves
track in particular in horse racing and
his own sons have not fulfilled his
ambitions athletically for them and he
becomes a father figure to Jesse Owens
he becomes the first white man really
who embraces who Jesse sees his color
blind and Jesse meets him shortly after
the family has made the great trek
northward from from Alabama to Cleveland
and he retains this relationship with
Riley throughout his adolescence and
young adulthood and all the way in fact
through the Olympics and then his other
coach is the coach who guides him at
Ohio State Larry Snyder who if Charles
Riley as a father figure
Larry Snyder's really like a big brother
he's only about 15 years older than
Jesse he competed at Ohio State himself
he's an altogether different kind of
influence on him but significant
nevertheless one of the things that
Larry Snyder did too was make sure that
the Jesse Owens was team captain at Ohio
State this at a time when African
Americans were not even allowed to live
on campus how unusual was that
distinction
oh very he was the first
african-american captain of any team at
Ohio State of course it would have been
ludicrous to have anyone else elected
team captain after what the things that
jesse achieved but nevertheless he
couldn't live on campus Columbus Ohio
obviously where Ohio State is situated
was
far from a bastion of progressiveness
and and jesse was such a highly
respected teenage athlete that the issue
of where he was going to attend college
was something debated in the Black Press
and many many observers thought he
should go to a school that had displayed
some progressivism some said he should
go to an historically black school
ultimately Jesse goes to Ohio State
because they find a way to help locate a
job for his father they find him a job
there's no such thing really is an
athletic scholarship then he has to you
know work odd jobs to make ends meet
he's already a father at this point but
he goes to Ohio State and as much as
he's living a segregated life there away
from the main body of the campus and
away from the white student body Larry
Snyder makes every effort to integrate
him and his other great competitor on
his team David Allbritton Jesse's best
friend going back to junior high school
on the team and make them feel welcome
when when Jesse Owens in college
competes against USC which was a track
powerhouse and again this after the the
annarbor made the Associated Press
refers to him as the super athlete of
modern times is this debatable in 1935
given the rise of Joe Lewis well you
gotta remember at this time I don't
think that uh when people after Ann
Arbor you know the records he said what
he's achieved there in under an hour has
made him this phenomenon and the laurels
are thrown at him from every corner he
starts reading the clippings himself he
follows up on that performance with a
series of similarly spectacular and
dominant performances he is at this
point though only the second most
popular African American athlete in the
country because Joe Lewis is is is this
undefeated heavyweight phenomenon and
he's coming along at a time in boxing
when the
the weight division has been a raft of a
true superstar since Jean tönnies
retirement in 1928 and so a lot of
people are extremely enthusiastic about
Joe Lewis particularly of course the
black community and even the white
community embraces Joe Lewis certainly
in a way that Jack Johnson who was an
anthem out of black America wasn't
embraced but Joe Lewis hasn't won the
championship yet you know it it would be
hard to call him the super athlete of
modern times or any other since he's
he's at this point an undefeated
challenger spectacular challenger
expected to shortly win the championship
which in fact doesn't happen of course
but Owens is already the best in the
world at what he does in a sport which
matters a great deal to many millions of
Americans and and what about rivals on
the track itself was ulis peacock in the
same class as Jesse Owens well that
that's the amazing thing about Jesse
Owens his summer of 1935 you know kind
of begins with Ann Arbor with the
spectacular achievement the six records
and then he goes to the west coast he
wins nine out of nine events in which
he's entered in the sprints and the
jumps he dominates the NCAA
Championships he dominates the dual meet
with USC but then you know his personal
life starts to intrude he realizes
pretty quickly that being a celebrity
has some drawbacks in particular he's
he's kind of exposed for courting a
beautiful young woman in Los Angeles
while he's out there this at the same
time that he has a fiancee and a child
back in Cleveland there are threats made
of breach of promise suits and so by the
time he gets the AAU Championships a few
weeks later in Nebraska he can't
concentrate anymore and he ends up
losing badly there in the sprints he
finishes third behind a fellow named
ulis peacock and a great Olympic
champion named Ralph Metcalfe
he loses the long jump as well which was
unthinkable to ulis peacock us peacock
goes on to beat him in four consecutive
sprints and peacocks totally different
than Jessie I mean physically Owens is
he's this beautiful you know young guy
he sees life he's five-ten he's 160
pounds he's perfectly proportioned ulis
peacock is a football player he's taller
he's stronger he's thicker and as
peacock starts beating him race after
race after race and in Owens is clearly
fatigued and some of the riders
recognize that other people including
Charlie paddock who had been the great
American sprinter of the 1920s says you
know what peacocks got his number you
know Owens goes from being this
spectacular betting favorite and every
event in the Olympics to being
downgraded to long shot after peacock
defeats him in several occasions and you
know every sports columnist in the
country the way you know today they're
writing about Terrell Owens or John
amici coming out of the closet is the
way they were talking about Jesse Owens
losing race after race everybody writing
about it and Owens himself is quoted as
saying boy you know I think I peaked in
May Ulis just seems to be getting
stronger and stronger I don't think I
can keep up with him and there were
serious analyses done of who start was
better who was gonna win this who was
gonna win that so ulis peacock was in
every way a very very serious challenge
Rollins here listening to meet the
author this is your NPR station 88 7 FM
wbf oh we're working from the Student
Union Theatre on the University at
Buffalo North Campus this evening our
guest is Jeremy Shep and I meet the
author selection his new book triumph
the untold story of Jesse Owens and
Hitler's Olympics Buffalo rising calm
the city's monthly print magazine and
daily website is proud to support
programming on WB fo Valhalla Rising
dot-com covers current events lifestyle
trends and civic issues with local
content that celebrates Buffalo and our
citizens available at retail locations
throughout the city and also available
online at
rising calm if there was a real threat
to Jesse Owens Olympic prospects it was
not just Ulis peacock but it was a
growing boycott movement that had been
gaining strength over the last couple of
years is this the first time that that
politics had really intruded upon the
modern games well it was I mean except
in the sense obviously there were no
Olympics in 1916 because of the First
World War that that exception aside I
would say so in to the best of my
knowledge it was the first time there
was serious talk of a boycott and the
boycott talk wasn't just in the US but
in Great Britain France around the world
there were a lot of democracies debating
the idea of whether to to participate in
the Olympics taking place in Hitler's
Germany the debate made more complicated
by the fact that games were awarded to
Germany 1931 before Hitler came to power
and people had to you know kind of take
a wait-and-see approach as to what was
going to happen but by 1934 only a year
into into Hitler's reign it was apparent
to enough people that what was going on
over there was was intolerable and there
were many many millions of people around
the world who fought very hard to see
their respective countries boycott the
games of the 11th Olympiad and the
winter games which were also taking
place in Germany in 1936 the fourth
Olympic Winter Games but you know it
became a very very heated political
discussion and there were a lot of
nuances to it and again it's a story
that I think people don't really
remember at all everybody knows of
course the US didn't go to Moscow in
1980 and the Soviets subsequently
boycotted Los Angeles and there were
various boycott boycotts and boycott
threats involving South Africa's
participation the games later on but
this is this is in many ways the
beginning at the politicization of the
game who is behind the boycott effort in
the
the boycott effort in the u.s.
surprisingly isn't engineered by a
Jewish politician or a Jewish
industrialist or it's engineered by an
Irish Catholic Tammany Hall politician
named Jeremiah T Mahoney who also
happened to be the president of the
Amateur Athletic Union which at the time
was responsible for certifying America's
Olympic athletes there's an American
Olympic Committee which pays for the
trip and is officially the US
representative at the in the Olympic
community but the AAU actually certifies
the athletes conducts the trials he is
the president of the AAU he's uh an
accomplished athlete himself he is much
he could have been a hero from ratio
Alger himself very you know born to
Irish immigrants worked himself through
NYU and NYU Law School became a
prominent judge and really worked
throughout his life to combat racism and
bigotry and his foil in this debate is
the former head of the AAU and the
current head of the American Olympic
Committee Avery Brundage who's got a
remarkably similar rags to riches story
but comes at it from a totally different
perspective what about moving the games
was moving the games ever considered
moving the games was considered it did
come up on several occasions there were
some of the choices well interestingly
enough the two nation's most eager to
host the games if they were taken away
from Germany were fascist Italy and
fascist Japan which should have given
people some indication that you know
there was more if Tojo and Mussolini and
Hitler all wanted the same thing let us
start wondering about motives and they
they campaign quite brazenly actually to
get the games relocated the games in
1940 were supposed to be in Tokyo anyway
eventually 1937 they take the games away
from Tokyo and after the invasion of
China
and they they award them to Helsinki of
course those games never took place
either but but there were plans afoot
and there were also plans for a
so-called people's games in Barcelona
which the Republican forces I shouldn't
say the Republican forces but those
people who favored the Republican side
in the Spanish Civil War which was just
getting underway were behind
Brundage ended up touring Germany as the
the boycott debate was going on what was
that tour like and and what did he learn
if anything well Brundage was
predisposed to what would happen was the
boycott movement got so far and there
was so much political will behind it not
just Mahoney but nine governors numerous
US Senators Congressmen some of the most
prominent citizens the country that
Brundage was forced from a public
relations perspective to go to Germany
for a essentially an inspection tour to
see if the Germans were in fact and the
issue was how they were treating not
only the Jewish citizenry but more to
the point if they were affording German
Jewish athletes a genuine opportunity to
compete for their Olympic teams so
Brundage goes on this fact-finding
mission but he'd already written a
letter to a publication suggesting that
he was predisposed to giving Germany the
benefit of the doubt and it's pretty
clear the Avery Brundage went winds up
being the most powerful person ever in
amateur athletics it's the head of the
International Olympic Committee was was
a racist he was an anti-semite and and
he was Germanna file he ends up later
life in fact marrying a German woman and
spending a great deal of his life in
Germany and dying in Germany what was
the what was the motivation for Brundage
in getting a team to Berlin for the
games when when the signs of
discrimination were so obvious the
Nuremberg Laws had had taken effect
German Jews were were stripped of their
citizenship there was not a Jewish
athlete on on the German team yet there
was this intense motivation one one
Jewish one on the winner team and one on
the summer team well what was the
motivation like getting the US
team to Berlin why was it so important
if the obvious injustice was was there
well he was I mean well he was
remarkably stubborn and he didn't want
to see anything intrude on the Olympics
I think that he was he was I there are
people who described him better than I'm
describing him now he was he was
remarkably intransigent and pigheaded
and that was really his great strength
and he he was principled in his in his
own way and he he couldn't see that it
was the Germans who were turning these
games into a political propaganda
spectacle he could only see that the
people who wanted to prevent the games
from being a success were turning it
into politics and and to him you know he
always stood fast I mean you know if
Avery Brundage were alive today and he
saw what the Olympics have become the
commercialization of the games you know
he'd be appalled and some of that you
could say is admirable and he wasn't
like a lot of the amateur officials who
simply didn't want to see the rich kids
compete I mean the rich the poor kids
compete against the rich kids he had
been a poor kid himself but he he really
believed in this this idea of the games
must go on
and that's that's more than anything
else his epitaph he's the head of the
International Olympic Committee at the
massacre in 1972 in Munich and the most
famous for words he ever uttered five
words five words or the games must go on
in the aftermath the massacre and that
was his attitude very much it's still
1935 as the debate is going on and you
do point this out in the book no one
could have foreseen the horrors that
were awaiting European Jewry yet as the
subject of German discrimination against
Jewish athletes was being discussed was
anyone in the press talking about
discrimination against african-americans
in this country well that's that's the
great you know irony to the whole thing
you know the Jesse Owens story has been
distilled for such a long time seven
years you know kind of the Cliff Notes
version you know grandson of slaves son
of sharecroppers goes to Hitler's Joe
he refutes theories of Aryan supremacy
gets his four gold medals end of story
but he was of course at the same time a
second-class citizen here in the US
there were so many opportunities denied
to him at that time that it's much more
complex than that and the boycott debate
is really interesting in the sense that
you've got some very principled
well-intentioned Americans saying we
cannot go to Hitler's Germany in any way
help legitimize this wholly evil regime
while at the same time other people
pointed out Jesse Owens couldn't check
into hotels in almost virtually in
virtually any American city not just the
deep south he couldn't eat in the same
restaurants with white Americans he
couldn't live in the same dorm at Ohio
State University as is why teammates so
the argument struck some obviously as
the height of hypocrisy not just black
Americans but you're telling you're
telling us we can't go to Hitler's
Germany because of the way he's treating
this miniscule Jewish minority and yet
look at the way we're treating our black
minority so you know this was a debate
that went back and forth did the
athletes weigh on this you know
collectively in Owens in particular how
did they feel about this debate well
Owens initially Jesse Jesse again he's
only 22 years old as this debate is
really taking shape and I think Jesse
the first time he's asked about it he
says well if that's if what you say is
true and they're really treating the
Jews as poorly as you say we shouldn't
be in Germany we shouldn't be over there
we shouldn't be supporting their economy
we shouldn't be giving them this
opportunity this propaganda opportunity
but then Larry Snyder essentially pulls
them aside and this is all there in the
contemporaneous accounts it tells them
Jesse what are you crazy
you want a boycott this is your chance
this is your only chance especially as a
black American how else are you going to
make an adequate living to support your
family how else are you going to rise
position society better than your father
and your grandfather and your aunts and
your uncles you have to go to the
Olympics and you are going to support
the anti-boycott forces and and besides
you know what difference is it gonna
make the games are gonna be there anyway
this is the argument Jesse listens to
and at the same time he gets impassioned
pleas from people in the boycott
community including the head of the
n-double a-c-p Walter White who writes
him this incredibly touching letter
beseeching him not to go to the Olympics
stating in essence that bigotry anywhere
is intolerable and you should not in any
way condone it even with your presence
even passively just by attending the
games and Jesse listens to the please
and like virtually every other athlete
who had a chance of being on the Olympic
team rejects them because essentially
that's what athletes do they want to
compete the only there were Jewish track
stars who competed in Berlin or did not
compete but went on the team to Berlin
and also Jesse recognized at some level
that you know if they say that we're
subhuman and they are the master race
how am I gonna disprove that if I'm not
there but I don't think that was that
was foremost in his thought process for
most was I'm an athlete I compete that's
what I do and this is my chance this is
your NPR station you're listening to WB
f o public radio from you be working
tonight from the Student Union Theatre
on the University at Buffalo North
Campus I want to invite some of the
audience and get the audience involved
in our discussion please your question
from Jeremy chef what do you think gave
Jesse his perseverance giving
unsurmountable odds and Hitler's
viewpoint what what gave him that
perseverance during this time I I think
Owens is he's remarkably cool under
pressure
he's been in pressure pack
situations before he was one of these
guys who found a way always to rise to
the occasion
I think his his coaches Larry Snyder and
Charles Riley were very important in
that regard and I think his mother was
very very important in that regard as
well
she had instilled in him from a very
early age the notion that he could be
special and he was one of ten children
there was no reason to believe that he
would be able to fulfill her hopes for
him but but she she really did I think
at a very early stage in his life give
him a confidence that remained with him
throughout and he was also really good I
mean he was just I mean you know that
kind of gets lost sometimes in the
discussion he just was really really
good at what he did and it's not you
know it's not it's not like a sport like
football or baseball or basketball where
it's about the competition you know
you're a track star you measure yourself
against a stopwatch from the time you're
competing sixteen you can telegraphic
aliy compete against everyone in the
world you just need somebody holding a
stopwatch at the other end and the
numbers didn't lie he knew how good he
was
and he knew that borrowing some kind of
significant injury there was no reason
that anybody should have been able to
defeat him
maybe food poisoning that was really the
his biggest fear more than any of the
competition it's fascinating reading
some of the some of the newspaper
accounts of the games themselves and of
of the events themselves Thomas Wolfe is
one of the more skeptical observers and
you point out writing in your book
triumphs the untold story of Jesse Owens
and Hitler's Olympics although the
Germans had packed away their uniforms
into closets and their anti-semitic
posters into warehouses they could not
hide what was in their hearts and the
thought of it made wolf shiver did so
many Western journalists miss what wolf
saw or did they just choose not to
acknowledge the the masquerading Nazi
agenda you know eight it's it's
interesting because you know as you
point out before this is 1936 this isn't
1938 the Nuremberg Laws stripping Jews
of the most basic rights have been
enacted the previous fall but there was
hope even among Germany's Jews that
things were going to get better not
worse than that Hitler basically reached
his nadir with the Nuremberg Laws and
from there things would stabilize and
certainly this is the delusion that not
only the Jews were suffering from but
the Western democracies as well in March
1936 he marches into the Rhineland he
violates the terms of the treaties of
Locarno and Versailles and nobody does
anything about it and he's emboldened by
that but this is two years before the
annexation of Austria this is two years
before he pressures the hand over the
sedate and land in Czechoslovakia this
is two years before crystal nacht and
he's trying to present a different face
you know where the Jews aren't gonna
have their full rights but they weren't
murdering people in the street and yet
the people who had been there covering
the regime in its first three years
could see what was happening and William
L Shire saw it very clearly in his
Diaries from the time the British
diplomat in charge in Berlin said you
guys are crazy you shouldn't send we
shouldn't be going to these games the
American envoy in Berlin Georg
Messersmith communicated the same things
to the State Department and yet there
were a lot of people smart people
who-who who chose to think that things
had gotten as bad as they were gonna get
I want to take another question from
from our theater audience please go
ahead in the Olympics Owens had already
won the hundred 220 in the broad jump
before these before the the relay could
you explain a little bit about the
decision to drop two jewish guys whose
times were fast enough so that the
foursome would have won that to drop
them in put Owens and another fellow
in their subs it's it's a complicated
story and it's a story that I think has
been missed old for a long time if you
want me to get into it in detail
jesse is won three gold medals in the
three individual events in which he's
competed everybody expects his Olympics
are over they think he's done the plan
had always been for him to compete in
the 200 yard
200 meter 100 meter dashes and the broad
jump and then to let everybody else get
their chance in the 4 by 100 meter relay
but after he wins his gold medal his
third gold medal 200 meters he starts
campaigning to be on the relay team and
that's something that you know hasn't
been written about in a long time quite
frankly probably 70 years and I was
surprised when I read the newspaper
stories and the archival research I did
it was right there and yet everything
nothing I had ever read about Owens had
pointed this out he wanted to run he
wanted a fourth gold medal the plan for
had been for him not to run ultimately
the two chief u.s. track coaches Lawson
Robertson and Dean Cromwell dropped the
only two Jews on the track team Sam
Stoller and Marty Glickman on the day of
the relay they are replaced by Owens
and you could are you could argue either
Ralph Metcalfe
or Floyd Draper at the end of the day
you end up with Ralph Metcalfe and Jesse
Owens were both black and for Draper and
Frank Wykoff who are both USC Trojans
Dean Cromwell was the coach at USC marty
glickman who would go on to become a
legendary broadcaster and one of the
finest gentlemen in the industry always
asserted that it was anti-semitism that
Brundage conspiring with Robertson and
Cromwell had the Jews removed from the
team so as not to embarrass their German
hosts by putting two Jews in the gold
medal platform because it was clear the
Americans were going to win the gold
medal regardless of which four of the
six they chose to run III don't think
it's quite that simple Sam Stoller the
other Jew removed from the team
felt differently for his part he thought
it was simply Dean Cromwell looking out
for the guys who ran for him at USC
rather than anti-semitism Frank Wykoff
one of those guys thought it was
anti-semitism Jesse Owens didn't think
it was anti-semitism
you know it's Rashomon I mean there are
million different ways to look at it and
[Applause]
I personally think it's a combination of
those factors certainly lost in
Robertson and Dean Cromwell would go on
to prove that there were no fans of
Jewish athletes but clearly Dean
Cromwell was also a fan of having two
more of his runners when two easy gold
medals in the 4 by 100 meter sprint
Robertson justified his decision by
saying that he had heard reports that
the Germans had been hiding their best
runners to surprise the Americans in the
400 meter relay which is demonstrably
absurd you can't hide world class
runners they had gotten their posteriors
kicked in the individual races and and
he said well it's my job to put the best
for guys I can out there on the track
especially because I'm hearing the
Germans you know have hidden these guys
well that doesn't make any sense either
on its face because in the other relay
the four by four hundred meter relay he
picks the four guys with the trials
finished third through sixth and the
guys who finished first second archie
williams and jimmy lavalle are not on
that relay they both happen to be black
they had won already the gold and the
bronze medals in the 400 meter
individual race a Brit had won the
silver medal and a Brit had coming forth
so you've got Americans finishing one
three and Brits finishing two four yet
neither of those guys runs in the relay
and the u.s. loses by a full two seconds
to Great Britain so that's a long way of
getting around to saying that he did he
wasn't being consistent logically but
the big controversies about what happens
in that meeting were announced is that
that it that Stoller and Glickman are
off Glickman always said that Jesse
stood up and said let Marty and Sam run
Owen said I never heard him I couldn't
any record of him having said that
having claimed to have said that I found
an instance where he said that he got up
and said let Sam run which makes more
sense because if he says like Marty and
Sam run he's volunteering somebody
else's position as well
Frank Ralph Metcalfe would become
Jessie's best friend and a four-term US
representative from Chicago not that
that's any indication of his propensity
for honesty always said that Jesse
didn't say a word I tend to believe that
Jesse after having campaigned all week
to be on the relay didn't say a word we
only have about 10 minutes left and
sorry I want to go to two other two
other events you were the the relay was
Owens fourth gold medal is unprecedented
fourth gold medal and one that many
thought he would never buy for but the
story that comes after his first gold
medal in the 100 meters and the idea of
of the Hitler's the the snub from from
Adolf Hitler where is the fact and where
is the fiction in this story this is
another hard one for me to be succinct
on but I'll try I promise this is if
there's one thing that most people know
or think they know about the 1936
Olympics it's that Adolf Hitler snubbed
Jesse Owens well it's it's a it's not
true it is true that Hitler did not
recognize him did not go out of his way
to congratulate him did not find a way
to acknowledge his achievement but the
sub story as Jesse Owens said at the
time was false what happened was this on
the first day of the competition two
Germans win gold medals Hitler takes him
up to his box
you know congratulate them very publicly
he goes out of his way to kowtow to them
and then three fins finish one two three
as was the custom and track back then in
the 10000 meters the Finns won
everything and these guys look more
Aryan they're more blond than the
Germans themselves and he congratulate
them as well very publicly now the other
competition that's going on that day is
the high jump and it's clearly the gold
medal is clearly going to go to Africa
American named Cornelius Johnson the
competition runs long though not because
because there's a jump off for the
silver and bronze medals between two
Americans delos Thurber who's white and
David all Britain Jesse Owens old friend
who's black so Hitler leaves before the
competition is decided it started to
rain he leaves now there's an uproar he
intentionally left so that he wouldn't
have to congratulate a black American
was clearly going to win the gold medal
if anybody has a right to feel snubbed
it was Cornelius Johnson the Germans for
their part imagine this this is a time
when Hitler wants to please as many
people as possible says no no no offense
intended
I was just scheduled to leave might be
true I don't think that he was looking
forward to shaking Cornelius Johnson's
hand but it might be true that he was
simply adhering to his schedule in any
event the head of the International
Olympic Committee is so upset about this
controversy that he reminds Hitler that
he's forbidden from congratulating
anyone unless he chooses to congratulate
everyone Hitler again eager to please at
this point exceeds to count on read the
by ayla towards the man and agrees not
to congratulate anyone by the time Jesse
Owens wins his first gold medal the next
day in the hundred meters he is honoring
his pledge he is not congratulating
anyone including Jesse Owens still the
stubb story becomes huge the papers
black and white in the US make it banner
headline forty eight point type across
the top of the page
Hitler snubs Jesse Jesse does everything
he can to tell people no I think he
waved at me once I swear he way to me
some of the writers think that Hitler
did kind of acknowledge them most of
them don't the only black reporters
covering the Olympics American black
reporters I should say for the
Pittsburgh courier they report a whole
story Jesse honored by Adolf Hitler it's
right there it's the opposite and Jesse
went on for a long time telling people
he wasn't snubbed but that wasn't the
story people want to be and to Jesse
Owens later say that the real snub came
from
at Roosevelt he did I mean this is
another interesting facet of the story I
mean how much you know that I was
unaware of for instance 1936 is really
the tipping point for african-americans
in this country between allegiance to
the party of Lincoln the Republican
Party and now the party of Franklin
Roosevelt Jesse Owens like Joe Lewis is
behind the curve like Joe Lewis he
campaigns for Alf Landen against
Franklin Roosevelt in 1936 and in fact
probably accepts $10,000 to do so and it
several stops on his stump tour he says
it wasn't Hitler who snubbed me it was
Franklin Roosevelt was there ever a more
unanticipated friendship to come out of
modern athletics than that between Jesse
Owens and looks long no this is this is
really um you know I mean it sounds
corny but it really is you know you've
got 22 year old poor kid from Alabama
grandson of slaves and you've got this
middle class highly educated blond
embodiment of the Aryan ideal and looks
long and looks long the story goes helps
Jesse qualify for the finals and long
jump when he fouls in his first two
attempts he comes up to him and his
spirit of true sportsmanship gives him
some advice Owens takes it Owens then
goes on two feet long in the final
spectacular duel between the two of them
the first person congratulate him is
looks long grabs him by the arm parades
around the Olympic infield arm and arm
you know this blonde German and this you
know African American full view of
Hitler they strike up I think what
becomes a very genuine friendship back
at the Olympic Village and if there's
one great tale of sportsmanship and
camaraderie and everything the Olympics
are supposed to embody it is I think the
friendship between looks long and Jesse
Owens and when you read from the
prologue in the book you had mentioned
it was 1955 and Jesse Owens was finally
getting his due why was that so so late
in coming why did it take so long for
Jesse Owens to realize the benefits of
his success in 1936 well I think there
are a few factors at play first of all
he gets back in 1936 and
laurels you know he is celebrated
there's no doubt about that
and people want to write stories about
him and want to hold him up as an
example of American strength in the face
of German aggression but they don't want
to give him a job and and he finds it
very hard to find his way financially he
is still very much you know I hate to
use the term constantly but a
second-class citizen while his teammates
who have won less and are less
celebrated you know go to Hollywood and
make movies and make money in bands etc
Glenn Morris becomes Tarzan and it's
also though effect or simply nostalgia I
think general rule in sports as in in
sports is you need 20 years to kind of
become an icon you know the the there's
the immediate after glow when everybody
loves you and then people kind of forget
and then World War two came and and
obviously people stop thinking about the
Olympics for a while but by the 50s as I
indicate in the prologue he becomes a
very convenient goodwill ambassador for
the US and for its way of life to hold
up as look you know the the Soviet
system is going around the world saying
look how they treat their blacks look
how they treat their minorities we can
do better for you and he goes around the
world to tell people you can do well
here when we look at and I was I was
really trying to focus on the timeline
how much time passed from Jesse Owens
fourth gold medal in the relay to the
time that Brundage had stripped him of
his amateur status one week and this is
Jesse Owens being forced as an unpaid
participant to take part in an
exhibition tour that the AAU is using to
fund the games and Jesse Owens mind you
with no endorsement contract is
literally dependent on passengers next
to him in a plane to eat no I mean it's
you know it's it's it's unspeakable
today what they did I mean he wins the 4
by 100 meter relay they say get on a
train right now you got to go to the
airport we're sending you to Cologne he
competes and meets in Cologne he
competes in two meet in Czechoslovakia
he competes in and meet in Germany he
competes in two meet in England all of
this while the Olympics are still going
on to put money in the a a use and the
AOC scoffer 'he's finally there's
another
the trip to Stockholm and all the time
remember Jesse's won four gold medals
he's getting telegrams come to New York
I'll give you $25,000 to appear with
Eddie Cantor with Bojangles and he's
sitting on these offers he thinks
they're gonna dry up it finally says you
and they don't give him a dime not even
a sandwich as you said and finally he
refuses to go in the last trip to
Stockholm you've been listening to meet
the author on your NPR station 88 7f MW
b fo our guest jeremy chef selection for
this month Jeremy's new book triumph the
untold story of Jesse Owens and Hitler's
Olympics coming up on meet the author
March 1970 clock and musical fare
theatres Carolyn smarts frost is here an
underground railroad story titled I've
got a home in glory land Michael Wallace
on April 24th also at musical fare that
selection billy the kid' the endless
ride and Thursday May 3rd a seven
o'clock start at the Roycroft Inn in
East Aurora our guest fred pierce will
be discussing his book with speed and
violence why scientists fear tipping
points in climate change I'd like to
thank the Vice President of Student
Affairs at the University at Buffalo for
all of his help Dennis black WB fos
general manager is Carole Petro Dave
Bender's Joan Wilson Mike McKay and Kara
sweet at the station as well our sound
engineer Jim back ratty with help
tonight from jerel Billings Doug Blakely
is our technical director Jo Geon oh and
Doug Morgan Oh provided our pre-show
music Johnny Garcia thanks for your help
at the student union theater at the
University at Buffalo North Campus
production assistance as well from
Debbie Simms and Kyle krycek thanks to
John well chat talking leaves books and
our sponsors this evening Buffalo rising
calm and the University at Buffalo
division of student affairs at channel 7
John de Julho Laodicea Linda Pellegrino
and Lorraine O'Donnell and thanks to our
members at WB fo as well whose financial
support makes all of our programming on
the radio station possible meet the
author is produced by Kelly Bocock
Natale I'm Bert Gambini Jeremy chef
thank you very much for coming to
Buffalo and visiting with us at the
University at Buffalo thank you Berta
thank all of you
Jeremy Shep is author of Cinderella man
James Braddock
Max Baer and the greatest upset in
boxing history his latest is triumph the
untold